follow your passion even when it sounds
crazy so I recently started a new
venture that's a little bit crazy the
business is called Gwanda gaming and
it's around a league of legends business
so legalized is a is a video game that
I've I've come to love and play and I'm
not that great at it but I have a lot of
fun with it and thought I want to try to
turn this into a business somehow
because the things I get passionate
about I find ways to incorporate into my
life and make it a business and so the
first step of what I'm doing is a launch
a YouTube channel surprise surprise on
doing video and I'm being coached by an
awesome league of legend coach who's
training me on how to get better and we
thought we'd record this series and put
them online the challenge was what am I
going to fit this into my schedule right
I've got a crazy schedule i'm doing a
lot of different projects what am I
going to make time for this and the only
time that I had was in the mornings and
so I set up my alarm I don't you just
sleep with an alarm but now I have an
alarm that goes off so that I can wake
up and play a video game and it sounds
crazy right you're setting an alarm so
you can wake up early to play a video
game and you know good luck trying to
explain that to other people even
explain it to myself but you know I woke
up an hour before that alarm went off I
wanted to make sure everything went
smoothly I was excited by it we had a
great first video there's more that I'm
gonna be coming out and that's the test
you know when you are excited by
something when you are passion about
something when you're willing to send an
alarm for something and then wake up
even before the alarm goes off that
tells you that you're on the right path
because too many people try to plan it
all out right trying to make make it
make sense up here in your head right
it's gotta make total logical sense
before I launch and your assumptions are
always going to be wrong and it's never
going to work out like you think it will
you spend so much time planning that you
don't spend any time doing and what you
need to do is follow your passion
even when it sounds crazy you know I
don't know how this business is going to
work out I don't know if it's going to
be with videos I don't know if it's
going to be through an agency through
tournaments through representing players
I don't know what it's going to be but
what I do know is if I don't do anything
nothing's gonna happen and so by
following my passion and by waking up
early and sitting that alarm clock and
getting excited about something we'll
explore will try will fail will make
mistakes and will get better and we'll
find our path and you need to do the
same thing too but there's something
that you are excited about something
that you want to try then start start
even if it doesn't make any sense
because by trying and making mistakes
and figuring it out you'll land on the
perfect business model to help you
explode and grow when everybody else
thought you were crazy believe you guys
like this video you want to see more
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much for watching I'll see you soon hi
ever kill English here with mermaid
junkie TV are you on Evans newsletter
subscription if not you should be I read
every single one and you should too
channel
you